look the porcupine tracker went right up
here it's not too far ahead this is a
fresh track
Hey look there he is right there right
in that tree porcupines when they're
getting chased they like to take to the
trees I can't shoot him with this rifle
oh this thing would make porcupine soup
out of that porcupine this is for
shooting big animals like caribou and
moose I don't have a smaller going me
today when I have to cut the tree you
got a little higher you got to think
about which way I want to drop that tree
if he goes over into that there's a real
good chance he'll get away under that
brush there I won't be able to get to
him if I make the tree fall this way
he'll be out in the open I got much
better chance of catching I'll put a
little notch here help guide this tree
down the way I want it to go there I got
the notch I'll direct the tree where I
want it to go
it's going there he goes
got it so porcupine falls out of a tree
and lands on your head that's what your
head could look like full of quills
porcupine a very good eating one of the
tastier animals I hear I'm a long way
from home I'm not gonna bring him back
whole
I got a butcher right here and it's
getting dark so I better get on it I'm
gonna start by skinning this porcupine
get the skin off without getting any
quills in me and I'll be happy look at
that fat that's hard to find out here a
lot of animals out in this country are
real lean it's hard to get enough fat
off the land a lot of times but
porcupines are one good source of fat
it's gonna be tasty head off cut the
hide off didn't get in quills in me I
just gotta get the guts out it's
interesting how one thing leads to the
next out here so off in the case I'll
head out thinking that I'm looking for
one thing but along the way I find
something else can't be too choosy and I
really like eating porcupines so I'm
real happy even though I didn't find any
caribou today that's where it goes
keeps life interesting time to get back
to camp go home and cook up some
porcupine